[Applause]
America's broken and it's up to you to
put it back together again it's a tall
order a lot of people believe in it but
you're not sure you do it'll take a lot
of lonely dangerous walks and
exceptionally heavy lifting and it's not
really clear what America means in the
first place for some reason you set out
anyway trudging through wetlands and
rocky hills on foot not fully knowing or
understanding where you're going other
than the monsters you can't quite see
there's not really anyone else around
most of the time just you and your
thoughts one foot in front of the other
on one level death stranding is about
America but your actual goal in setting
out across the country is to help people
bring them together and forge
connections not for the vague concept of
America but for the sake of helping
people death stranding is unrelenting in
its earnestness and optimism certainly
not without its critiques of America nor
without its challenges and setbacks but
inherently hopeful nonetheless it is a
dense complex slow game with a plot that
really goes places but at its core it
never stops being about the sheer power
and purpose we can find in human
connection and that is its most
remarkable achievement
rebuilding the country is as simple as
getting every far-flung city outpost and
individual onto one network the bones of
which were laid down by a pseudo
government organization called bridges
as Sam Porter bridges played by Norman
Reedus all you have to do to win people
over is bring them packages most people
never go outside you two mysterious
monsters called BTS but unlike most
people Sam can sense them enough to
sneak past them and get important cargo
to its destination
deliveries can be arduous you're
evaluated on your deliveries across a
few categories but the condition of your
cargo can make or break a run and there
are a lot of factors working against you
on top of BTS you have to contend with
time fall a kind of rain that rapidly
accelerates aging and deterioration for
most of the things it touches extended
exposure to time fall can damage or
completely ruin your cargo as can
slipping and falling getting hit by an
enemy or in some cases just being a
little too rough with it even the
smallest rocks can trip you up too in
order to keep your footing you need to
pay close attention to where you're
stepping keeping your balance with the
triggers will on rough terrain or when
carrying a lot of stuff once you reach
your destination though you're showered
with praise the recipient will likely
thank you to your face albeit as a
hologram and then they'll give you a
series of social media style likes
you're inundated with a multi-page
result screen itemizing all the likes
you receive for the delivery and in
which categories plus an overall rating
for the delivery itself and no matter
how small it's positive reinforcement
turned up to 11 these likes then funnel
into each of the delivery categories
like experience points and as you level
up you can carry more weight or better
maintain your balance among other
benefits deliveries also feed into a
connection rating with each city outpost
or person and as that increases you
acquire better gear and sometimes gifts
to reward your efforts further in short
you give a lot and get a lot in return
there is a relatively small number of
mandatory deliveries to advance the
story but there's a seemingly unlimited
number of optional deliveries and I
often found myself picking up orders
destined for any place that was on my
way it's a cycle that's easy to get
swept up in no matter how difficult to
delivery or how far the distance you
will at least be met with gratitude
likely feel fulfilled
having completed a tough delivery and
often given a tool to make future
deliveries a bit easier
most importantly though increasing your
bonds with people is how you get them on
the network and the network is what
elevates this core loop beyond the
simple satisfaction of completing tasks
and getting rewards
[Music]
the chiral Network is a kind of
souped-up Internet that allows you to 3d
print objects which is incredibly useful
and a strong incentive in itself when at
a terminal connected to the chiral
Network you can print ladders and ropes
for traversal new boots as yours wear
out repairs brave or damaged containers
and basically anything else you need to
safely deliver cargo so long as you have
a blueprint for it you can also print a
portable printer that builds structures
for you out in open areas covered by the
network things like bridges watchtowers
and generators the latter of which are
critical as you start to use battery
powered exoskeletons and vehicles the
chiral Network also grants you access to
the online component of the game which
is absolutely essential you never see
other players in the flesh but their
impact is all around you once an area is
on the network you can see structures
and objects left behind by other players
in the course of their own journeys plus
helpful signs they've put down just for
those who come after them you can pick
up someone else's lost cargo and deliver
it for them too knowing someone else may
find yours at some point and do you the
same kindness in death strandings best
moments the relief and gratitude you can
feel towards someone you don't even know
is an unrivaled multiplayer experience a
climbing rope left behind by someone
else can be your lifeline as you stand
alone at the edge of a cliff with almost
no stamina left they probably just put
it there because they needed it but it
can feel like in that exact moment they
knew exactly what you needed you can
give and receive likes for these player
2 player structures and just like with
standard deliveries the strong incentive
to do something helpful for someone else
in the earlier sections of the game I
was using other people's structures far
more than I was leaving behind help for
others but I wanted to pay it forward
and know that my hope was appreciated so
I started going out of my way to build
structures I myself didn't really need
at first the like system seems like a
pretty obvious commentary on social
media and our dependence on external
validation but it's not so much a
critique as it is a positive spin on a
very human need for acceptance and the
system does a remarkable job of urging
you to do your best for NPCs and real
people alike feeling truly appreciated
can be a rare occurrence in life and
it's powerful in its simplicity here the
first few hours of the game are the
slowest and a large part of that is
because you don't have access to the
online component right away
it's an incredibly lonely stretch of
time during which you mostly just walk
the work you do early on is especially
laborious in the absence of advanced
gear and it serves to give you an
appreciation for other players and
better gears you move forward but even
as the gameplay opens up you continue to
get a lot of story exposition with
almost no explanation it can all seem
kind of goofy at first and you can get
lost in the metaphors every city you
need to add to the chiral Network has
not in its name for example and they are
all referred to as knots on a strand
that connects the country there's a
bizarre and unwarranted product
placement in the form of Monster energy
drinks and the show ride with Norman
Reedus Guillermo del Toro's likeness is
used for a kind of dorky character
called Deadman and there's a woman named
fragile in a game about delivering
packages but the story really does go
deeper than that in keeping with the
theme of human connection each of the
core characters you meet and work with
has their own story to tell they all
have a unique perspective on death that
lends them an equally unique perspective
on life and unraveling their characters
down to the true origins if they're
often literal names contributes to the
overall tapestry of death strandings
take on the human experience as they
open up to Sam Sam opens up to them in
turn growing into a distinct character
in his own right out of the reserved
emotionless man he appears to be at the
start I grew to love Sam fragile and
Hartman especially and even the ones I
didn't like as much add to the game's
overall message about hope and love in
the face of adversity
the necessary maintenance has been
completed various adjustments and
fine-tuning for your benefit you can use
it again
[Music]
for once it would seem that Doom's and
bb's are a good combination by far my
favorite character and the most
important one is Bibi babies are infants
in pods that can detect the presence of
BT's and they're issued to porters like
Sam to help them navigate dangerous
territory you're told to treat bb's like
equipment not real babies but it's
impossible to think of your bb that way
it's full of personality giggling when
happy and crying when stressed out it
even gives you likes from time to time
there aren't many children left and
death strandings isolated fearful world
but bebe is your reminder that the
future is counting on you regardless of
how you feel about America itself the
love that grows between Sam and bebe is
nothing short of heartwarming connecting
with this story just as with connecting
with NPCs and other players can take
work it's not a story that immediately
clicks on a surface level and the
dramatic mystery and off-the-wall
science don't make too much sense at
first blush but it's an emotional story
first and foremost and making sense of
these things while entirely possible
particularly if you read the letters and
interviews that details small bits of
lore as you go is not as important as
reflecting on how it makes you feel you
have plenty of opportunities to do that
too in the quiet moments of travel
usually as you near your destination
music might start to play the soundtrack
which is largely composed of one band
low roar is phenomenal the kind of
contemplative focus music that suits a
trip alone through a meadow or down a
mountain because the act of walking is
so involved it's not a time to detach
completely and zone out it's a time to
feel your feelings or at least consider
what's next in your travels
[Music]
you can just as soon be ripped out of
that headspace though by a shift to the
haunting music that signals bt territory
the otherworldly growls of BTS as they
close and on you can be terrifying and
early on your best bet is to freeze in
your tracks and hold your breath for as
long as you can so you can quietly sneak
by them but there are times when you
have to fight a BT in its true form and
for that you have specialized weapons to
take them down
these beetee's aren't the ethereal
humanoid shapes that float above the
ground but huge eldritch Horrors that
screech under clouds of blood the combat
is mechanically simple you mostly have
to move around a bit and hit them before
they hit you but the sequences are
visually and aurally arresting you don't
get a gun that works on live enemies
until 25 or so hours in but even then
it's non-lethal you are actively guided
away from killing a death stranding
because when people die their bodies
basically go nuclear in level cities
leaving nothing but craters and feeties
in their awake on top of that the main
human enemies are mules former Porter's
just like Sam that had been corrupted by
an automated world they've essentially
become addicted to snatching cargo in
their desperation to have a job and a
purpose as more and more people become
replaced by machines they're not evil
and killing them seems like well
overkill it's easy enough to knock them
out with the non-lethal methods you
continue to unlock as the game
progresses I didn't kill a single one in
my playthrough though punching them is
satisfying
while beetee's and mules are concerned
while delivering cargo
there's also Mads Mikkelsen z--
character a man who's introduced through
memories Sam sees when he connects to B
B's pod he gets his own dedicated
segments that punctuate hours of simple
deliveries and these highly contained
much shorter sections are striking in
their art direction and juxtaposition to
the rest of the game it's not
immediately clear what he is whether
it's an enemy a potential friend or
something else entirely but he's
captivating in his ambiguity the most
cartoonish enemy is Troy Baker's Higgs a
terrorist whose depravity seems to know
no bounds of all the characters Higgs is
the weakest with far less and he wants
to him than anyone else in the cast he's
really just there is a big bad to
motivate you in a more traditional video
game sense than delivering packages and
helping people but he and his band of
faceless terrorists are Morra means to
an end than full-fledged villains he's
the catalyst for some of the major BTW
fights and in the end perhaps an extreme
reminder that it's possible to stay
hopeful even when things are darkest
death stranding is a hard game to absorb
there are many intertwining threads to
its plot and silly names corny moments
and heavy exposition belie an otherwise
very simple message that comes through
much more clearly in the game as more
mundane moments when you find a
desperately needed ladder left behind by
another player or receive a letter from
an NPC thanking you for your efforts
it's positive without ignoring pain in
fact it argues in both its story and its
gameplay that adversity itself is what
makes things worth doing and life worth
living
it's a game that requires patience
compassion and love and it's also one we
really need right now
you